And now the old scout master.
So it was a year or two ago that we were on a canoe trip with the Scouts-
Gorgeous weather, beautiful conditions, just it was on this lovely river
And unfortunately we got stuck-
And it's not very common to get stuck on a canoe trip, but it was the weekend
And we couldn't get out until Monday morning when the banks opened.
Yeah,
Hey, this is podcast number 97..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green. Hey, as promised,
we've got three members of the National Advancement Committee for an interview in this podcast.
The National Advancement Committee produced the new Guide to Advancement
and the new Eagle Project workbook that has been published this fall
And what I wanted to do is I wanted to get a few members of that committee together
so that they could discuss the way that this kind of thing happens.
You know we're unit level volunteers-
We have. you know we're scout masters and assistant scout masters, committee people,
Cub masters and Cub committee and all you know- and venturing people and everything.
We're pretty concentrated day to day and week to week on our Scouts, working with them.
You know, we probably understand something about how a district functions
and we understand how a council functions, but how does our national organization function?
How do things like the new Guide to Advancement come into being?
Well, this podcast should give you some answers about that.
What you'll find is is that the people who are on the National Advancement Committee are volunteers like you and I.
They have broader interest than you and I as volunteers because they're looking at the program from a national level.
Hopefully, what you'll find is what I found in speaking to them.
They're pretty down-to-earth guys.
I mean, they are just, you know, very experienced scouters who
who dedicate a lot of time on our behalf and the behalf of our Scouts,
and they put really valuable tools like this Advancement Guide into our hands
so that we can directly affect the program with our Scouts,
And that's the way that it works.
I was very excited to speak with them and I was very happy with the result.
I hope you are too,
And that interview is going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
I also want to note that you know, last week I said that this interview was coming up
and I solicited some questions, and all the questions I received I really appreciate
and I was able to fold some of them into the interview.
Some of them were really specific policy questions that I want to save for another time.
and when you listen to the interview towards the end, you're going to find out
how you can get in touch with the National Advancement Committee,
and there's also going to be a link in the post that contains this podcast to an email address
so you can send your questions directly to the National Advancement Committee.
How about that?
I think we had best get started, shall we?
So joining us today on the Scout Master Podcast are three members of the National Advancement Committee.
Steve Bowen is out in El Centro, California, and Steve is Area 6
or Western Region Program Support Chairman.
He's also a member of the National Program Content Committee.
He is a team leader for the Merit Badge Advancement Activities for the upcoming 2013 National Jamboree.
He's also earned this Distinguished Eagle Scout Award and the Silver Buffalo.
How are you doing this evening, Steve?
Very fine. thank you, Clark.
And Wayne Huddleson is in Omaha, Nebraska, where he is a National Advancement Committee Eagle Rank and Palms Specialist.
He's also a Silver Beaver recipient, and Wayne was involved in something many of you have seen,
and that was the Union Pacific Railroad Locomotive that was set up and had the Special Paint Scheme for the Centenary.
Wayne was part of making that happen,
So we owe you some thanks for that, Wayne. How are you doing?
Glad to be here, Clark.
Finally, Dan Maxfield is in Fresno, California, where he's the Council Vice President for District Operations,
the Area Vice President for Council Support on the National Commissioner Support Staff.
Dan was also part of the editorial team that produced the 2010 Centenary Boy Scout Handbook
and he's also a Silver Antelope recipient.
So good evening, Dan. How are you?
Great tonight and glad to be here with you, Clark.
Well, I want to say I really appreciate you guys taking the time to do this as a part of what you do for scouting,
And the reason I asked you to be here was to give scout leaders an idea of how things like this new Guide to Advancement happen.
This fall, the BSA released a significant new resource for us volunteers, and that is that Guide to Advancement
replaces the publication that used to be called the Advancement Committee Policies and Procedures Manual,
and it features some significant changes and clarifications.
One of the things I'm really interested in is how things like this happen.
How do you end up on the National Advancement Team?
Well, this is Steve. I'll start off.
The previous Advancement Committee was one of many national committees
and the new Advancement Committee has actually kind of evolved back into a full-time committee
because Advancement is something that goes on all the time.
But people were asked to be on that committee who had backgrounds in different special areas,
maybe some previous Advancement Committee work,
but generally they were selected from across the nation for their different expertise in different fields.
So this team gets together and then what kind of information or statistics or input do you use
to put together something like the Guide to Advancement?
Well, this is, Dan, The process that the National BSA uses now on anything like this.
the way they're developed is through a committee structure that includes a lot of folks from around the country.
At any given time that could be 50 to 100 folks- and those folks are surveyed through email
and phone conversations. data is collected, it's collated
and then a smaller group of folks will take all that data, formulate something that says:
well, we think this is maybe what's the result of that data,
and then put that back out to all of those folks and say: is this what you told us?
Get some input, refine and develop that down to something that then everybody tends to buy in
or agree on after some discussion and interaction over time
and then that becomes the product.
But I should point out here that the material is written by a small group or a single individual,
and in the case of the Guide to Advancement, by a single individual,
simply because there's a need for a continuity of voice and content,
and a committee trying to write something like that would not have that characteristic.
so typically something like this today is being written by one individual,
with constant guidance and interaction from a group of folks.
You're soliciting opinions and information from volunteers like me.
You betcha,
It's not done in a vacuum. in other words,
No. in the case of the Guide to Advancement,
there were over 50 volunteers around the country that gave ongoing input,
plus about 50 professionals that gave feedback into this whole process as well.
but it's important to understand once a viable draft is developed.
this goes to health and safety, it goes to special needs,
it goes to legal and all the different departments within the BSA
to make sure that all of the opponents of the Boy Scouts of America
are in accord and in agreement, so that there's a one voice coming out of this thing.
Clark, I'd like to add something.
This is Steve
Over the years and Dan and I were on that Old Advancement Committee
for about 15 years apiece. a lot of things came up repeatedly
The same problem in Eagle Appeals or a Board of Review or something like that.
A log was kept that picked up these problems
and that became another resource for developing this new guide
to cover all those little issues that just kept being problems.
That actually comes from the field.
In our discussion before we started, you guys mentioned too
that committee also answers Eagle Appeals and things like that.
so you're dealing with direct things on an ongoing basis.
Absolutely correct,
This is Wayne.
One of the things that you see and you've mentioned in some of your other podcasts
is some of the changes. things to the project forms and things like that
were in response to some of the problems that Steve's talking about,
where he was taking months to get approval for a project
or things like that. that seemed excessive.
You see some clarification in the guide now in those areas.
This is Dan.
I would add to that as well that we teach classes at FilmWant
during the summer and we teach classes at the sea base
during the January timeframe.
That's a little commercial right there
in case anybody's interested in signing up for those,
But at those classes we interact directly face-to-face
with volunteers from the field and they tell us this stuff
and we kept this information from them
and we have a lot of face-to-face discussions
that give us a good sense of what's out there in the field
and how do they feel about it.
About how long did this whole process take, would you guess?
I'd say it took about a year.
Do you guys agree with that?
This is Steve.
There were some changes to the guide in 2009,
but they just weren't what was necessary,
and so a whole new guide was developed.
Chris Hunt at the National Office
has really been the torch bearer for this.
I would say, like Dan says, a year,
maybe probably two years, if you think all the time
that was kind of built in re-evaluating the previous document.
It was a full, solid year of direct writing and interaction.
We had a preliminary draft in January,
so actually a lot of work had gone on before then.
How did you resolve debates or questions
that may have been a bit of a problem
or there were different opinions.
The thing is that when divergences of opinions would come in-
and many cases Chris Hunt, whom Steve alluded to a moment ago,
would simply call those people directly and say:
look, here's what you said, why,
and would get their input and interaction
and would give him the feedback from some of the rest of us
that he was hearing and say:
well, look, this is what I'm hearing from others.
Are you in agreement here
or is there a major disagreement? or can we resolve this?
And more often than not, most of it was resolved
simply that way.
One or two things were fairly contentious
and I think eventually Chris had to simply say
the majority believed this. so that's what I'm going with.
This is Wayne, and one thing to keep in mind
is it's intended that this document's a living document.
Another reason for it being on the internet
is you can see this thing change
or be updated as conditions warrant.
New information comes in, that gets considered
and things like that.
We don't anticipate going 10 years before changing it again.
I guess, with the way that the internet
has enabled a lot of this stuff,
it's easier to get input now,
it's easier to make the changes,
it's easier to publish the changes.
The downside of that is, like you say,
it's easier to get input,
and the problem is sometimes you get so much of it,
you become overburdened,
and that was some of the problems that the group faced too
was trying to deal with so many opinions
and so many places at the same time.
The one thing that I absolutely was thrilled with
as I sat and read the new guide
was the emphasis of a proportional approach
to advancement as one method of many in scouting.
All of us have known for a long, long time
that advancement is just one of the eight methods
of Boy Scout program development.
Advancement is the one that everybody sees, I think,
but there are so many other kind of subtle things
which are part of the methods of scouting.
So this is not the whole nutshell,
this is just a portion of it,
And this is Dan.
I would point out that I absolutely echo
what Steve just said.
but there was clearly a recognition
on the part of the folk that put together
the current Journey to Excellent program
that we're now on,
which to the point that it became a specific item
in the Journey to Excellence criterion,
because it's very clear over studies over time
that when kids in a unit-
whether it's Cub Scouts, Boy Scouts, Venturing,
it doesn't matter- are having fun
and they're learning something,
they tend to stay longer in the program,
and ultimately that is our goal, isn't it?
The most problematic part of this sometimes
is just getting it right,
is getting that right balance:
being able to run an advancement program
and have all the other things happening at the same time
without over-emphasizing one or the other.
This is Ryan. let me build a little bit on that.
One of the things I want to point out is,
if we think back about what we do in scouting,
what we want from scouting,
we're really looking for excellence in character,
citizenship and fitness.
Even though they're earning these awards,
what we're really hoping for
is a lot of time of excellence
by living by the Scouts of St Louis.
I think the guide is really going to help us
reach those goals
and I think it really helps.
it really lays a very clear path
on how to administer the advancement part of the program.
The kids don't know
how we're administering a program
and what we're trying to, where our goals are.
All they know is, like Dan said,
are they having fun, are they learning something?
and oh, am I advancing
because I get another patch to put on the uniform?
and mom and dad are kind of thinking
somewhat the same thing in some cases.
I mean, they're looking, hopefully
that Johnny's going to become a better citizen down the road,
but they don't realize
all those other subtleties that we are
ingraining in their children
through the program,
and so advancement is one of those little carrots,
but it's not the whole
salad.
When you open the guide and you start reading,
one of the first things that you come across
is there is a list
of 13 significant changes that were made.
I wanted to just
bring up a couple that really came to my attention,
because I think
that they elegantly put to rest
some issues that seem to come up time and time
and time again on a unit level.
The first is
the concept of reasonable
expectations, As it concerns
active participation
and fulfilling requirements for positions
of responsibility. there's now
this really great three-step test
to determining
active for a scout rank.
What fomented that particular
change in clarification?
Well, I was just going to give a little history on that. first,
because I think it's the old
policies
and procedures of advancement
had a number of
rewrites, but they were only
segments that were rewritten,
and we've tackled the
active one a number of times
over the years. The discussion
then became
we needed to look at the boys' life
in general. This age
had other things going on, and
that's where we seem to have most of our problems
with appeals
and boards of review was
this very strict, narrow
line of what active was,
and there was
this ongoing debate about
the number of camp
outs- a kid had to go on and stuff like that.
So there's been
an evolution of this to where we are today.
Well, this way,
my understanding is a lot of this was
driven by input from the field.
We talked earlier about all of the surveying
and stuff that was going on.
You'll find units where they want to treat it
like a sports program. You're either in
scouts or you're not. You're either 100%
with us or you're against us.
That's not the kind of program we want.
We want an inclusive program in scouting,
not one that excludes kids.
They all got things, other things
going on in life, just like we adults have
other stuff going on.
We tried to make everything
so it was a level playing field
across the country.
If we had some units that were saying
you had to have 75% of your activities
to be consider active
and we had ones on the other part of the country
that were saying, well, if you come once
or twice a month or whatever,
there wasn't a standard and so
it wasn't a level playing field.
Johnny, in one part of the country could not.
maybe it was 10 times tougher
than somebody on the other side of the country.
That was one of our concerns
and it was one of the debating points
for years as to how
do we keep a level playing field,
and I think what we came up with
was a very kind of honest
compromise.
I think it's brilliant. It seems also
to have enough latitude, if a unit does
have this kind of metric
requirement, that they can use
that to a certain extent. They also
are required to look at
the boys life
outside of scouting and what is involvement
and things there are.
One of the things that it specifically
mentions in the guide is that
the purpose of Starlife and Eagle Scout
requirements are
to develop an impact
are you having on their lives
in the program at that point
and they may have absorbed the
ideals of scouting and are off now
as captain of the football team
and are leading the debate team at school
and doing all kinds of things that are character building
and citizenship and fitness building-
all the kind of things we're hoping to
develop in these young men.
One of the things we discovered,
Clark, was that there was just too much arguing
out in the field over what constituted
active anyway, and no matter
what we said
year after year after year,
we would continue to
discover that units all over the place
were saying: well, you have
to be at 75% of the
meetings, 80% of the outings,
you have to wear your uniform
69.2% of the time
and you better not miss any courts of honor.
and
we were having to
argue with people everywhere.
and so in this case,
what we kind of
in effect said is:
we don't want to argue about this anymore,
it has to be reasonable.
and so what's going to constitute
reasonable? you units out there
go ahead and say whatever you want,
set up whatever standard you care to set up,
but when it comes to the board of review,
the board of review is going to
determine what's reasonable based upon
the guidelines in this book.
and if it gets to the national level
and to the the ego
issues, folks,
and you've set these things that are outlandish
and unreasonable, we are going to overturn you.
so just understand that
There's a similar set of
standards that apply
to evaluating positions of responsibility.
the guide talks
about positions of responsibility.
I think. is that the same as
leadership positions? is that
kind of interchangeable, or is there a difference there?
well, this way in. the actual requirement
for ego rank
reads
following positions of responsibility.
a lot of people say leadership,
but you know the real strict reading
of the requirements.
that's the terminology they use,
so that's why we used it in the guide.
there are some jobs
that really aren't leadership jobs.
as scribe, librarian
historian- I mean
historian- doesn't lead the boys into the woods.
he does a job
and so his responsibility is,
whatever the definition
and the job tasks
are for the historian. so
if he does those jobs-
that's why we use the word responsibility,
because that's his responsibility
rather than a leadership role.
when you talk about positions
of responsibility and evaluating them, in the guide,
again you've given a very clear
path for volunteers to use
in making those evaluations
and it involves,
again, a reasonable standard.
it involves
the scout
having to understood and
agree to that standard
and then the ongoing
mentoring and discussion
process that needs to go on between a scout
and a leader as he
is
fulfilling that position of responsibility.
is that a pretty accurate?
yeah, and we wanted those unit leaders
to talk with those kids,
not just say:
here's the job,
go do it and in six months
I'll tell you
whether you passed or not. we want those unit leaders
to talk to those kids and work with them.
if the kids 14,
he may have a different capability
of fulfilling that
than a kid who's
going on 18
in the band, on the football team
and in the debate team
and active in his church.
and leaders need to be able to sit
and talk with those kids
and deal with the reality of their lives.
so you guys were
seeing that misunderstanding
of that, or how did you
come to address?
there were a number of appeals, for example,
where a boy would be in a position-
he'd be 17 and a half
and 17
and nine months, let's say, and he just finished-
he thought he'd finished his six months
in a position of responsibility
and the scout master would say, well, he didn't do a very good job,
so I'm not going to count that
now. he's only got three months before he's 18,
so he can't do it over.
so he gets kind of ambushed
trying to eliminate that stuff.
right, you got to talk to the kids in advance.
how are they doing? it's just like a job review at work.
you know they don't wait until
the end of the year, until you get into a good job
and you don't get your pay raise.
they pay every month,
and I think that's an important distinction.
I think we've
kind of defaulted to calling everything
a leadership position
when actually the language
doesn't call anything really a leadership position.
we talk about leadership,
we foment it,
we mentor it, we want it to happen,
but
these are all positions of responsibility.
some of them involve leadership and some of them don't.
absolutely correct, and that goes even-
you will see
in the redefinition
of some of the terminology
in the new eagle project
workbook that that's even the case.
we continue to call that
a leadership project. well,
okay, but
is there more going on than just
the exercise of leadership? is that all
we're expecting from the boy?
well, no, it isn't.
so. is that one of the aspects
of it? well, absolutely, it is
showing that
through all of these other things we've asked
them to do, tasks that we've
asked them to do that we call
responsibility positions.
over time that he's actually learned
something and he can show us that he's learned it.
but there's way more going on
in that project that purely
the exercise of leadership.
and in fact in the guide there's a specific
section that addresses the
responsibility and leadership issue.
that's a 4.2,
3.4.6,
how about that?
but
many suggest the requirements should be
called for a position of leadership rather than
simply responsibility. but taking and accepting
responsibility is a key foundation
leadership. that's one of the ways
the guide explains that.
you did bring up the numbers there, Wayne,
and I've had a couple people kind of roll
their eyes at the numbering system. why is
the numbering system there? because
that allows us to know
exactly where we want to go
in a section to look
up something and if we want to change
something, we know what section
is in and we can change that
and relate it to where else
it might need to be changed by a section
number. as opposed to
page 39, paragraph 2,
sentence 1, word 6.
it's an easier
definition system of where
stuff is for reference
purposes and for
change purposes,
because you can expand all of those sections
with the number of digits
and things that are in there. that was one
of the frustrations of using the old
advancement
committee policies and procedures guide.
was that reference to a page
trying to figure out if you found
exactly what they were talking about.
so yeah, and then
is this thing evolves on the internet
in between printed copies. you know if
you might add enough to something
that it's going to force some text over into
a different page. so if you tell people it's on page
15 but looking on the internet it may
not be on 15 anymore, it might be on 16,
but it's still under section
4.1.1.0.
so there's also
some clarifications about boards of review.
I think there was a couple of procedural
changes, slight procedural changes
and clarifications there. can you give me
kind of an overview of that? the first
thing that that occurred there-
that's that's new- is it
says that a boy must
be granted a border review
when the requirements have been met
or when he believes
they have been met, and that's a huge
difference from what we've had
before. that was one
thing. and secondly, the uniform issue
was clarified big time
in that section because there's always
controversy over that and I hope we put
that to rest. and then
we clarified
the issue of what do we do
when a unit leader
or the unit committee
chairperson won't sign
a boy's application,
because that had always been
a problem and that
became what we call now a disputed
circumstance issue.
and the reference issue
about what references are required
and how are they handled was cleaned
up big time. has the guy
been out yet long enough to see its
effect with appeals and things
like that? this is Steve. I don't know
about appeals, but I was at
a training session up in
Utah and
they were already using it and referring
to it and
many of them new things about it
that I didn't know. I mean, it was
very well accepted and these
Utah councils are big councils.
most people there that came up
afterwards said, boy, this is sure made our job
easier. and we
were hearing- at least I am, I'm hearing-
from folks
as I talk to them just in one place
or another that they're reading this
over now and it's
making so much more sense and they're really
delighted with many of their clarifications.
the totality
of this thing doesn't come into
absolute implementation
until January
1st, and so
those that are picking up and using it now
are doing so at their discretion, because
they can but they don't have
to. we had roundtable
Tuesday night and the
district advancement chairman
was talking to everybody about the
guide and she was very, very positive
about how it was going to make a lot
of people's lives a lot easier.
and one of the things we're really trying to do is get this
out to not only
the unit leaders but to the parents
and everybody that's involved in the program.
you know everybody needs to read this and understand it.
everybody thinks they know
what advancements about, but this is the
thing that helps them really understand what it's about.
I noticed the difference between
this and the document that it's
supplanted. it kind of, in the title, implied
that it was just for the advancement committee, but
this is truly written for everybody
to look at. the
advancement committee has
a cub scout person,
a venturing person, a boy scout
specialist, a merit badge person,
an eagle person,
a disabilities person, a training person.
I mean, they're all at the same table.
and when this book was produced,
one of the things that Chris Hunt
specifically did
was went to the professional
in charge of the
seat scout program and said: look, we need to
make this one voice.
how is this supposed to read? and look.
and they did that. and he went to the
special needs people and said: we need
to make this one voice so that
everybody understands and we're all on the same
page. what should this look like
and sound like? and that's what they did,
and that- that's exactly what Steve was
alluding to- is that we now
have the capability of bringing all those
folks to the table so that we come out
with with one package and one
voice, as opposed to this
discontinued product.
well, another, another, another very
positive thing, though, is with all these same people
at the table, now you begin
to really focus on making
the program
development.
you know, from cub
scouts through weeblows
to boy scouts to venturing
to make you may,
you may have a continuum. that's going to be a
little easier to little easier to establish,
and, along with the
new guide to advancement,
there is a new
Eagle Scout project workbook
and there's some new language
in the guide to advancement that
pertains to some Eagle Scout stuff.
what were the
principal things that you hope to
clarify and
change in
what we were finding out, Clark?
in many cases around
the country, this project was
being turned into a master's thesis,
and kids were coming to the
council office and turning in a binder
that was four inches thick
and that this stuff had been gone over
and seen, inspected, as if they were
doing a doctoral dissertation,
and- and at the beginning, even before
that, in case after
case after case after case, in district
after district, all over the place, kids
would come to
a district committee
to review their project
proposal that we called it in those days.
they would be turned down and they would come
back and say, well, you got to fix this.
and they come back and they'd say, well,
you fixed that, but you didn't fix this,
and they turned them down again. and
then they'd say, we'll fix this.
they'd come back and, well, you fixed this,
but not enough. we wanted more.
and what we were finding was that
even before a kid got a proposal
approved,
he'd already been through four, five
or six of these things
and in many cases it was just turning kids off
and they were saying, to heck with it.
we had to take this process
and re-grab it
back and say, wait,
this is not a master's thesis,
a doctoral dissertation,
you're not becoming an engineer.
this is just a little
thing for a kid to go out
in the community, display
what he's learned in the Boy Scouts,
exercise some leadership,
learn some processes about how to put things together
and organize and direct
people, and then,
once they see I finished this
and we wanted to
put it back on, that perspective
and this
that was coming to us from the field
in overwhelming
voice: this is too generic,
too simple. people don't understand it
and they're turning it into something
it was not intended to be.
please clarify this thing
and streamline it,
and that was what was intended.
one thing that I had
when I read the new
project manual
was the differentiation between a project proposal
and a project plan.
yeah, I've been fighting
with that for
quite a long time
and I was so pleased to see that somebody
finally saw that
and set it out so that a scout
didn't have to, as you said,
have a dissertation level project plan
all sorted out to the last penny,
to the last nail, before his project got approved,
that he needed to propose the project
first and then develop the plan.
right, and the concept
of this-
putting this preliminary proposal
together- was simply:
does this thing have
a shot
at being completed
and being something that we want
to be an ego scale level
kind of project that's going to fulfill
the objectives of this thing?
if the answer is yes, then let him go.
you don't want this project
to become-
I mean, you want it to be a positive memory
for the kid,
not something that was
such a tough thing to get through
that he regrets having to
put all that effort into it.
he wants to remember it in a positive manner
and be able to do it at a scale that
matches his abilities.
I think it was you that said it, Dan,
an expression that goes out in the community
and is an expression of
what he's learned as a scout.
were there any other
things about the new project workbook
or the ego process
that changed significantly or clarified?
you may have picked this up already
or not. I'm sure you have
but notice that
once the boy has had that
initial first section
signed off and then at the end
there's the completed plan,
the completed write up,
that section in the middle, that actual plan piece,
he doesn't even actually have to do that
if he doesn't want to.
did you notice that?
I had a little back and forth with a friend of mine about that.
we looked at it.
he was a little put off because he thought that it was going to
kind of lock them down
into having to fill out
this long form type of thing. and I said-
you know the way I'm reading this.
he can do whatever he wants
in the way of expressing his plan.
nobody can force him to do anything above
and beyond about what's described here.
he can take any form that
he wants to use.
if the boy chooses
not to do that
section- the actual plan piece-
because no signature is required there
and he comes to a board of review
without that
and the board says, well, we don't really understand what you
accomplished or how.
in your final write up
you don't really tell us
how this was accomplished
or how much money you actually used
you gave it back to, or
how many kids you actually had to
employ and what difficulties you had.
we think we're missing some stuff.
can you explain that to us?
and the boy can't explain it.
he may have a problem at his board of review.
so that's there as an ability
for him to
work out the nuts and bolts if he needs to,
and then actually have something
to take to a board of review later
to support what he wants to tell him.
but he doesn't have to do that.
we didn't require it.
Clark, that's very clear
on the front page of the final plan.
it says specifically in there
that the final plan is a tool for your use
and it's not approved or signed.
so it's really important that people
read that front page.
a lot of times people flip over the front page
and start reading the inside
and getting to work. it's like: well,
read the front page.
another big change in this
is the concept of a project,
alex to have one.
it's just another
resource for the boy.
it can be the person who
is the eagle project
signatory
approval person, but it doesn't have to be-
and, again, the coach doesn't
have to even exist either. but it's one of these things
that we are suggesting is another resource
for the boy.
I think a lot of people were using an eagle
advisor type of thing,
but it's nice to see
it more formalized
in that way and to encourage
a scout to go ahead and find somebody
to help them out like that
and see. that's one of those subtle. other methods
of scouting is quality adult
association.
one of the little subtle things I'd like to
note is when it talks about
project approvals. you know there are
steps you're supposed to go through. you get the unit leader,
the unit committee, the beneficiary
and typically a counselor or district approver.
but from time to time
scouts jump the gun and they get ahead of the game
and they get going on
their project and maybe even get it
completed.
there are talks about that.
we need to give some consideration rather than
just saying, well, you didn't get approval,
you got to do it all, you got to do a whole different project.
you got to look at what the kids
done with the project and perhaps
consider leniency there rather than just an arbitrary
no
again and again.
what I've come across in the new guide to advancement
of the new Eagle Scout materials
is kind of-
it's kind of- reminiscent of the baseball
role of a tag: always goes to the runner
when in doubt. we trust
what scouts are telling us and we look
for ways for them to succeed rather
than ways to fail them.
that's the theory. don't throw up barriers.
help the kids. this is a process
of coaching, mentoring and helping,
not sticking your leg out to triple.
I'm going to be,
I'm a unit level
volunteer. I have a question or a difficulty
or problem of some kind.
I look at the new guide to advancement, I look
at over pretty carefully,
but I'm not really finding the answer that I
want. what do I do next? call your unit
commissioner huh, Dan, I'd say
so. so I
I start going up the trail, I get to the
unit, commissioner, and- and he's looking at it
to- and we're not really able to
get a final idea
of where to go forward. then what?
what are we up to? your district advancement
here? so, if there, if we, if we
exhaust all the resources that we have in
our district and our council on some
question. where do we go next?
there's a place to ask questions
of the advancement committee on the national
website listed in the guide
to. I was just looking for it. I thought it was
right in the front. it's advancement
and it says it's on page
six of the guide. it says
suggestions,
questions
and comments to the advancement
team. it's advancement
dot team at scouting
dot org. make sure that it's posted
on the blog in the post that
contains this podcast. and once again
I would. I would point out that
even these, these advanced, these
unit level folks can come
to film on during the summer
or the sea base in January and
take the advancement mechanics
of advancement course and and we'll tell
them all the stuff they need to know there too
and they can talk with us direct.
we've even done a few special classes
that and when we can get a group
together. is there anything that I've missed
that
you think people ought to know about this new
guide to advancement,
Clark what? one of the other things that
I think we're hoping
as a result of the product of this
new book
and the new
eagle project
workbook is that
there's enough
clear information and enough
clear determination of what's
supposed to happen and how
councils can focus on
the issue of advancement
and units can focus on the issue of
good program with advancement
built in, and they can stop
spending their time writing documents about
how to do all this stuff.
I'd like to add one thing
to it just: you gotta
make sure that you do good advancement records.
if there's one thing that we
aren't able to fix
in this guide,
it's shabby records or
non-existent records or
problem records. and if I could
stand on the soapbox and
and beg everybody to do one thing
is to really address their
record system, because all this
is great, but if you don't have records,
it's going to pay the price down the road.
now I want to tell you
how much I appreciate
the work that you guys did, along with
the rest of the advancement team.
I hope you're getting a lot of
pats on the back about this,
because I can imagine
you know a year long
process was probably pretty trying
at times, but I think it was
so well worth it
and we
it'll be a little while before we see
the full effect. it really is
going to help scouts- that's
what I think,
and I really appreciate your involvement in it.
well, the guy who really
needs a pat on the back
and he won't take. it is Chris Hunt.
he did a yeoman's task here,
putting all this together
and getting it straight lined,
and he's a very good writer,
and I don't think any of this would
have been possible without Chris's efforts
and I echo that.
and then also
thanks to you,
Clark, for trying to help us
spread this message.
it's just incredibly important
and it makes life so much better
as a scout leader. when you have these things
nailed down. it just makes life
much, much easier and you can
actually do what you're hoping to do.
gentlemen, I want to thank you once again
for joining us on the scout master
podcast. I think we just
started to scratch the surface of the usefulness
and the scope of this new guide
to advancement and the new Eagle scout materials.
I think it'll make
scouting a lot better for scouts
out there and really do appreciate
your work. so,
Dan out in Fresno, thanks for having joined us.
thank you for inviting me.
Steve out there in El Centro,
thanks for being part of the discussion.
thank you very much for having us. Clark
and Wayne in
Frosty, Old Omaha, Nebraska,
thanks, thanks again for joining us.
thank you, Clark, it's really been a pleasure.
well, thank you for listening to this edition
of the scout master podcast.
let me tell you how to keep in touch.
you can read the scout master
blog at
scoutmastercgcom
while you're there. you can subscribe
to get email updates about the blog
or subscribe by rss, however you like.
you can also subscribe to the scout
master podcast.
you can also subscribe
to the scout master podcast.
to the scout master podcast on iTunes
when you do, feel free to leave
a comment or review or a rating.
finally, you can also
access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher smart radio
and you can get details about that
at Stitchercom.
you can call and leave me a voicemail,
comment or question at
484-734-0002.
you can also experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on facebook.
you can tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmaster circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
if you don't tweet,
if you don't face,
if you don't plus,
well, you can email me.
how about that?
you can send your comments
and questions
and wild ideas
to scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
I need to remind you
that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
just me with a microphone and a telephone
and whatever other phones there are out there,
trying to help scout leaders
and have a bit of fun along the way.
I hope you don't mind.
will you allow me just
one kind of personal moment here.
our first grandchild,
our granddaughter Sawyer,
was born this past week.
and Sawyer, welcome to the world.
it's a great place to be,
isn't it
so before we go,
let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Beaton Powell.
Sir Robert,
I highly recommend
the scoutmaster podcast.
good luck to you and good camping,
why? thank you, sir,
until next time,
you
you.